so before we went out we said natalie
said we're going to have you name your
favorite kardashian who do you like
kardashian
doesn't mean kardashian do you know the
kardashians it's even better i don't
know
is that english that's english i've
never heard them they're romanian but
yes they're english the kardashians
you've got a crush on helen mirren
yeah she's sexy she is
do you know that i have made out with
helen mirren
i saw i saw she kissed you in the mouth
yeah
was that hard for you to watch knowing
that you got a crush on helen mirren but
i am kissing
i was just wondering how your wife felt
about that
rob riggle claims he used to be a marine
but he also claims he's now a comedian
so i don't know what to believe
rob served in afghanistan before
becoming a stand-up comic then the real
bombing began
well this has been a lot of fun mrs
clinton we should stay in touch what's
the best way to reach you email
you've stopped doing them though haven't
you kids yes
yeah wow yeah i watch it every night
before bed almost my wife says why are
you watching him again i said i don't
know i like the show
i like seeing your face before it's
reassuring you're like
you should not be watching me before you
go to bed well that's not a good image
my wife likes it because it acts as a
sort of contraceptive she knows
you know she knows i'm not going to be
in the mood
they want you to give us a quick count
to 10 both of you gentlemen if you don't
mind just if you wouldn't mind counting
to 10. now you can only count the five
10.
well premier magazine's list of the 100
most powerful people in hollywood hit
the newsstands this month in an odd bit
of ranking demi moore was ranked number
28
while
her breasts were ranked 20 and 21 so
and i just don't feel like we're gonna
accomplish that when he's showing more
cleavage than brittany and i are friends
then show more cleavage yeah i'm good
thank you okay well so am i i'm not
showing any cleavage this is a t-shirt
i'm surprised because normally you could
like braid your chest hair
tell her to stop picking on me don't
pick on him he's a kind man who's never
insulted anyone uh
phyllis stiller you're a dear friend and
i must tell you god bless you
god has given you the way you look
do not be ashamed of it when you were
born you probably hit the wall
like i saw this make-a-wish kid and he
said has it ever been anyone that you
ever wanted to meet that you got to meet
i was like oh the other day i met tom
cruise and he was like
oh man i didn't think of him
but he wasted his wish on me
i could have had tom cruise who needs
the most lotion my nomination is for
shaq and those ashy ankles
chicken flower before
[Applause]
that's because
that's because your mother had to work
last night
in an interview out this week
demi moore says she would like to have
another baby this time a boy to go along
with her three daughters and two huge
breasts
my guest today is jerry sindesk seinfeld
really thrilled to be here
simon you have said that you find demi
lovato annoying you have said that yes
to to many people you've said that to
the press she's here with you right now
uh let's have at it why would you say
something yeah let's clear it up you are
very annoying thanks
how does that how's that where you are
you could be a bit of an [ __ ]
when i heard that i would be the first
speaker in tonight i think maybe
somebody made a mistake
don't laugh
because i think this spa belonged to
great iron iverson
and why
because i need more practice than him
[Applause]
look at all these beautiful people here
to pay tribute to you the senator rich
little paul lind on the end paul if you
want to order do it now the kitchen's
going to close
sorry about your seat paul why don't you
get a pillow so you can see us
who do you think would give you the
hardest fight out of anybody on stage
right here
right here the hardest hitting 145 pound
the real hardest hitting 145 right here
this guy tko's people when i knock
people out they don't [ __ ] move
who the [ __ ] is that guy
oh this is
i saw you knocked down that jump shot
yesterday that was nice i shoot better
than you
tell you a little secret about this
he was wonderful in that dwayne's got a
tattoo right above his ass that says
come on
like one of my the biggest parts of my
life if that even makes sense um i have
what i used to call a super sniffer you
guys watch psych when you're little
because i love that show i watched it
when i was little
[Laughter]
um
[Music]
you get offended by being called the
wrong name i do you do yeah who did they
mistake you for i went to correct no i
went to work
that was that was really good
that was really good man demi moore is
wrapped filming on g.i jane
in which she plays a navy navy seal
combat officer moore says that in
contrast to other hollywood portrayals
of women in the military her character
will have giant breasts
[Applause]
together and you get those tables that
face each other to each other having a
massage we may have gone to a spa what's
a massage
what do you think good question massage
okay it is massage
well but you're in this country
if you do win an award tonight
pl don't use it as a platform to make a
political speech right you're in no
position to lecture the public about
anything you know nothing about the real
world most of you spent less time in
school than greta thundberg so if you
win right
come up accept your little award thank
your agent and your god
so
it's already three hours long so rebel
are you a big fan of game of thrones
i have to admit i'd never seen game of
thrones
[Music]
the view is so spectacular for me i mean
everyone looks so tiny yeah
as opposed to you who looks tiny all the
time
what does that mean oh no no just
because you're short and i'm tall like
watch stand up stand up yeah
you see no i don't okay never mind
actor bruce willis is filming his next
movie the broadway brawler in wilmington
delaware meanwhile his wife demi moore
is taking a break from movie work saying
she wants to spend more time with her
huge breasts
but emmett you know i'm here for
basically two reasons first reason is
i'm a big big fan of yours second reason
is shaq sent me a beautiful letter
saying he wanted me to come and it was
for charity and it was really from shaq
because it was signed shack